China's rise isn't so successful not
only because of the smart policy
decisions that they took from 1978
onwards in terms of opening to the
global economy and the way in which
they've directed resources towards
production and export but it's also that
global economy itself that has
catapulted and buttress China's rise
because China is the globalized super
power without globalization it wouldn't
be able to harness or or achieve the
kind of revenues that it has from the
global marketplace so China is the
poster child for global economic
integration leading to greater national
power and that is the number one reason
why China